current state i think that's a little
unfair i wouldn't call her crazy
oh okay here's here's the story so we
pulled this up from the federal list
here's what i love the federal list
is called fake news by news guard but
this story is like 100 legit
over at barry weiss's sub stack katie
herzog wrote about this interviewed this
person
and the federalist writes it up they get
called fake news but it's like it's 100
verifiable
lecturer at official yale event
fantasizes about brutally murdering
white people
claims all white people are rotten i
don't know if i can read what she said
on youtube
i don't think you but well let me just
put it this way
it's not something somebody should be
able to get away with saying on a
college campus considering the
environment we're in politically and
also the fact that there have been mass
shootings in educational settings
repeatedly
it's kind of a horrible theme how much
can we divulge about what
i'll paraphrase okay she said she wanted
to take a weapon
and unload it on any random white person
she saw she fantasizes about this
yes and i'm like that is not well and
then she goes on to say that
she's i think she said something like
white people uh like lie
about food she said we're deranged yeah
she said
she said she said she said after making
this quote which i will not repeat
because i might
botch it and get us demonetized that
white people are deranged
uh and her talk was on the psychopathic
problem of the white mind so i don't
know what they expect actually then yeah
yeah
the psychopathic problem of the white
mind i don't know what they thought she
was going to talk about what she was
going to say but yes it did involve
using a weapon using a weapon against
the head putting
placing it to the head of a person and
um i'm not sure how much yeah
i'm not getting in trouble here tim in
an official lecture called the
psychopathic problem of the white mind
given by aruna
kilanon kilani yeah wow at the yale
school of medicine's department of child
study center kelani graphically
described her fantasy about killing and
burying white people i'm not going to
read them
normal college stuff yeah you know
sounds like slam poetry
yeah exactly she's just delivering a
little slam poem dude talk about
murdering the english language
oh my goodness fair enough well played
so here's
so obviously this lady's psychotic and
this is really
this is we're getting into seriously
dangerous territory what's fascinating
is that there are a lot of people i
think like scott adams
was talking about how all of the white
privilege stuff was bubbling into i
mean maybe it wasn't scott adams but
correct me if i'm wrong i talk about how
like this rhetoric will lead to genocide
yeah all these cartoonists making great
points yeah that was scott right yeah
that's good
and it's funny because like um i
wouldn't say he's 100 right just yet i'm
not saying he's wrong i'm saying
where we're at so far is it's escalated
from white people are inherently racist
to a lady saying she fantasizes about
just randomly killing white people and
i'm like
yo we're getting dangerously close but
we've already heard a lot of this so i
many people probably know i was down on
the ground in mil in
uh wisconsin and they were at it was
that it was like a black lives matter
protest and they were screaming get the
white people shoot the white people
wow we've heard a lot of that stuff at a
lot of these events
so maybe we've already been at this
point but now it's institutionalized now
you have yale lecturer being straight up
being like this is what i want to
fantasize about this is what i do
and this is what's insane so she was
previously a professor she taught at
cornell columbia and new york university
which is fantastic to have a professor
going out there saying things like they
want to
kill people of a specific race but also
she's a psychiatrist which to me seems
strange i don't know that this is a
person who i would want to go to for
psychological help
she likes i can't even make some of
these jokes i know it's just
it's like it's dude it's so over the top
right there she said white people sound
demented and it's just crazy to me that
she was able to get through this speech
you can't all right
first of all the thought of even going
on a college campus
and talking about intentionally harming
people being violent against them
with a deadly weapon i would imagine is
enough to get you thrown off even if
it's not
racially based you're not but you know
talking about a specific group of people
it seems to me it's like saying bomb on
an airplane or something
i can't believe right there's there's a
difference between telling people to do
something
and to say you're fantasizing about
doing it but i mean there's
now also kind of not really a difference
i know and i know that this is like the
cliche thing that every conservative
says imagine if the situations were
reversed but seriously
i just imagine any professor going out
there and picking out a racial minority
and saying that they wanted to do
this to them yeah also it would be on
the front page of everything and it
would be used
as an excuse to censor every other
conservative so so
you're gonna love this this is this is
the caliber of people now
lecturing at these universities so in
the interview katie says
uh could you give me an example of what
of how this is picked up in all aspects
of culture how do you see the after
effects of colonialism manifesting
itself in the white mind today
this woman this crazy lady says it's
gonna be hard for me to give you one
sentence sound bite on this but i would
say a high level of guilt
i've never seen anything like this
before other than in white people not
eating bread
an incredible level of shame feeling
really exposed all the time
a lot of perfectionist tendencies and so
some
somehow like it's it like seems like
katie's trying to have like a honest
conversation but this lady's like
bread they don't eat bread and then she
goes on to say
uh let me let me find like white so it
does seem like you generalize a lot this
is katie about white people
but also people of color why do you do
that and this woman says why do you feel
uh what do you feel is a generalization
katie asks
like white people having a high level of
guilt or not eating bread that's true
for some
that's true for some people for sure but
i eat bread and then she says you don't
think you're generalizing the lady goes
on
and and somehow it it comes back to this
sure this is katie there are a lot of
white people who don't eat bread
although i am not one of them i
exclusively eat bread
i don't think katie excuses
however she goes on also i'm skeptic
skeptical of some claims of gluten
intolerance but my assumption has always
been
that they're just buying into
pseudoscientific bs and following health
needs
you think it's white guilt the lady goes
on an emotional level absolutely
like if i raise an eyebrow at a white
person around bread
the first response is like it's real
what does that mean
they mean it's not psychological right
it's a medical issue not a mental one
says katie
the lady goes i don't deny that people
make it symptoms
but how is it that all these people
suddenly now after all the violence has
occurred are not eating bread
it's like the weirdest effing thing
katie says but what does bread have to
do with violence what's the connection
there i think the bread is about guilt
and needing to keep them in a state of
deprivation and
stay guilty okay
that's the famous bread section of this
lady's interview that's brilliant
now could you imagine paying that person
to go to a college and teach your
children
you may notice white people not eating
bread why because they're racist
guess what i want to do to them this is
what we have to do to wipe them for not
eating bread ladies and gentlemen this
is the only solution you heard about
that socialist want breadlines guess
what something much worse
we don't want anyone having any bread
dude yell did there's at least the
footage
obviously for good reason and she claims
it's because they're trying to suppress
her
it's like first did you imagine like
she's in a starbucks and the lady's like
the message needs to be censored i know
like the well the message needs to be
too real part of me wonders if like yale
is just kind of trying to help her by
downplaying this because they know the
more it gets out there the worse this
person's life is going to be i'm not
sure what y'all's motivations are
maybe they're helping her with their
silence as dave chappelle would say
or did say this is the kind of thing
where it's like this instance like
like this lady will be in a subway or
something and someone will be like
um do you have anything without bread
and then she looks and goes
like you remember body snatchers when
donald tutherland's like
like she's not eating bread it proves it
i thought i thought amber max kendy's
thing was crazy when he was like
denying racism is proof of racism i was
like well that's nuts
now we've got i'm sorry this is crazier
if you don't eat bread you're racist
i just realized i'm black wait a second
okay so i coming over here driving right
i had in my car
cold cuts pastrami turkey listen in a in
a ziploc bag and i'm reaching
into the ziploc bag with my bare hands
and eating the cold cuts
no bread i'm black
but that's actually cool because you
were racist yeah she said if you don't
know i've only been black for a little
while no no she says
you're racist yes wait she's not saying
white people even i'm actually saying
white people don't so it's racist
to not eat bread so am i correct here
i'm trying to figure out the rules right
now i don't want this lady to come to my
house remember
i don't remember when milk was a racist
yes it was quite
weird now you only get lactate well it's
because asian people don't drink milk i
guess black people don't either
really yeah is that a thing yeah it is
actually it is yeah in other countries
people tend to lose their tolerance for
milk as they mature
i've heard people don't for whatever
reason there are definitely genetic
differences you know
like um sickle cell anemia seems to have
striked the african-american community
harder than other
you know genetic races or whatever
that's not that's not true
that's true yeah sickle cell anemia was
like notably found in in like african
culture no racist social construct ian
oh well that's true
yeah i i have nowhere to go so not so
now just wait what
you do the door's right there maybe you
still have somewhere to maybe certain
people are more sensitive to gluten
intolerance i don't know is there
something to that i've never heard that
before
is there anything right or anything it's
really an ice
yeah that's a good alternative to ice
cream
you don't you know what they they do
that's that's racist they make bread out
of mushroom yeah she's talking about
gluten right
not bread like i could have my idea i
don't know
i have no idea what she's talking about
i have no idea what she's talking about
i'm so confused about this woman other
than she's did you get your violence
privileged check in the mail this week
though
i did not i didn't oh wow who's the king
of white is it trump does trump send out
the checks
yes yeah and i i got what i got i'm
getting wait i got it i got an email
from trump and he was like tim
no you're not white i'm sorry you're
part asian
you don't get a check you get two
biscuits chips
how do we pay for our two million dollar
apartment
oh my gosh i'm gonna eat only bread i
can't afford anything is okay boomer
girl right
i have no idea because i think like they
just they they just now will say they
are
they aren't even if they they are she's
latinx though latinx
latinx latinos like kleenex yeah yeah
like kleenex i hear how it's pronounced
latinx or is it latinx yeah i don't know
like kleenex latinx yeah okay
like latino latina latinx that's great
and how much how
there we go yes college women it's a
white college woman mostly too probably
yeah it is yeah definitely everything
has to be cleansed including language
they love it when you uh cleanse their
language yeah when you yes exactly yes
people from other cultures love when
white people come
around and tell them that their culture
is actually insensitive i have my latinx
friends that i have to go over
to their house and just like hey i heard
you talking yeah in your
fake language that's not real anymore
hold on hold on like where where is
where's the person just kind of roll
with this to like go to one of these
meetings or hang out with some woke
people
and just absolutely play into it oh that
was what art school was for me
so when they when they say like latinx
you go oh oh oh honey
no no no no we don't we don't say latinx
anymore because it's not inclusive
of you know uh you know i don't name
name x-ray
i'd be like so now we say latini
yeah and what are they gonna say to you
they're going to be like i don't i don't
know well yeah no
no we we we we we don't want to be
racist do you yeah exactly
like how come no one does that just goes
in there and just make actually
maybe that's what's happening maybe all
this that's why it's getting so
ridiculous it's actually people who
don't even believe the stuff trying to
screw with them oh baby frank
yeah well come on man have you seen like
there there were activists in canada
complaining about chick-fil-a
and i was doing i was covering the story
and i was reading an article it was like
the activists literally wrote the
i lgbtqia a two no no it was like it was
like
l g b t q i a t r o b f n
two plus q absolutely i'm i'm i'm trying
to remember the best i'm getting wrong
but it was like 15 or 16 letters yes
and so when i'm reading it i'm like the
activists wrote this message saying we
stand in solidarity with the lgbtq iap2
plus tr ob
ny x3 community and i'm like i literally
have no idea what that means i'm not
trying to be disrespectful i'm literally
like i
i don't know the message you're trying
to convey to me about chick-fil-a
there's too many letters there to learn
the right code and then there's another
one
there's another code that's like
trans-indigenous
yeah trans-indigenous people of color
and like other
it's like it's like tapocany or
something like that like at some point
you lose the entire purpose of having a
group and
the point of an acronym is you're
supposed to keep it short right it's
supposed to be something that like
everyone can just say
you need to remember people easy to
remember and also it's supposed to refer
to like a limited group of people so you
start tacking on all these letters and
it defeats the entire purpose
like the fired act that one was fouchy
incompetence requires early dismissal
yeah that's brilliant
excellent fire the guy yeah yeah but
that's why i'm i'm confused because i
wonder why it is people don't speak up
and just say outright like this is
like not communicable you know what i
mean like i don't know
what it is you're convinced oh they're
scared all of them are scared that's the
thing too i wonder how many of them
actually believe this because i met a
number of people again
i was sort of joking earlier about art
school but i met a number of people who
behind closed doors
wouldn't say all this far left stuff in
fact they would agree with me that
um the left has gone off the deep end a
lot of the other students were
really too far to the left and made them
feel uncomfortable to voice their own
opinions
but and then i guess i ended up
wondering is that
really true or do you just kind of say
whatever the group is saying and so now
that you're around me you're saying
something you think i might agree with
it's hard to know but i
imagine there's a large number of these
people who do think it's way over the
top who do think it's a little silly
maybe they believe in the cause but they
think all these extra letters are
ridiculous but they're just not going to
say it because they're terrified well
you know you know what will happen if
these people do
it's not even necessarily about getting
cancelled it's about just a a net
detriment
to their lives yeah exactly you don't
want to get put down as the racist you
don't want to have to be lectured at and
educated by your friends
it's not even that it's a homophobia i
won't i i won't get a speaking position
or i'll get a worse grade or uh you know
people will
start saying mean things about me on
facebook it's just like i don't want to
deal with the stress
this woman lecturing at yale will point
a weapon at me do you think
she uh graded white students fairly
yeah no yeah no definitely not
she's like f she like she has a name and
it's like
like patrice you know mcdonald and she's
like f
and then the woman walks in and she's
actually not white and she's like oh and
she turns into an
and she just draws the line it's an a
now she's like i'm so sorry reminds me
of that that softbank episode where
michael jackson moves to south park
ignorant and the cops are like a wealthy
black man moved in so they like
raid the house and then the cops like
wait a minute he's not black he's white
and like my god what have we done
they like regret it yeah this is the
this is the nature of yeah the culture
where these days wait was that the same
episode
when they had uh the crosses no yeah
no no that was different
that was when it's called that one was
called there comes here comes the
neighborhood or whatever
okay and it was about all the wealthy
like celebrity black families moving in
man old south park yeah yeah the new
south park's like not even
the good stuff man we had the best
childhood
as far as like cartoons go i wasn't
allowed to watch that stuff man i don't
know whose childhood you're talking
about
90s babies what were the raciest
cartoons you saw
well as a kid i mean like i wasn't
really i think i mentioned this before i
wasn't allowed to watch the simpsons but
i started watching it as i got a little
bit older i think once i was like 10 or
11 my parents didn't care about it as
much but
we also didn't have cables so i couldn't
watch a lot of these early seasons of
simpsons were the best
oh yeah no i'm a huge fan i've watched
basically every episode until like maybe
season 25 or something it's horrible now
i'm sure you know that now we had like
adult swim back in the day like i
remember i went out stay at my cousin's
house yeah i was thinking about uh
mtv cartoons from like like daria is one
of my favorite cartoons of all time for
instance
so dry so i've heard good things
sarcastic
it's it's actually uh no not mike judge
all right so beavis and butthead was
mike judge yeah it's a spin-off right
cause she's right it was a spin-off
right
but it just it's very smart comedy i
like the
nowadays like i don't actually love the
seth macfarlane stuff so much anymore
it's more like gaggish yeah 100 as
opposed to
i don't know cultural commentary well
that's the thing like
gags are great to take you through
something really short but when it's
like 22
minutes long and i'm supposed to be
roped into a story i kind of stopped
caring about it when
my attention is brought in every
different direction for some short cheap
joke
so i hear you especially with the
mcfarland stuff i think they have a
thing where every 10 seconds or
something we have to do a joke even if
it's a flashback well that reminds me of
the time i
yeah exactly it doesn't really advance
the story at all
comedy or something thanks for checking
out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast if you want to see the full
show
come back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl
monday through friday at 8 pm where you
can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you